ce matin 20 kg de poireaux sont livrés à
la cuisine centrale de Villemandeur des
légumes cultivés à quelques kilomètres
de là dans le Gâtinais par l'un des 10
agriculteurs qui travaille avec la
légumerie carotte patate douce pomme de
terre depuis le mois de septembre tu te
découper et conditionnée ici avoir des
collectivités qui vont nous commander
une fois par semaine ou deux ou trois
fois il y a des jours où on a énormément
de commande avec 600 kg à traiter par
exemple et des jours on a 10 kg c'est
vrai que c'est très très aléatoire pour
ce travail la pagaie embaucher 6
personnes en insertion un revenu qui va
améliorer le quotidien de ces femmes
mais pendant toute la durée de leur
contrat qui peut aller jusqu'à 2 ans
elles seront t'accompagner pour trouver
un emploi plus durable ce nouveau poste
à la légumerie c'est un tremplin j'ai
toujours pas le permis encore je le
passe et grâce à elle alpaguer je peux
me mettre à mon permis en même temps et
après voir pour être assistante de vie
comme je voudrais faire
elle travaille 24 heures par semaine à
temps partiel qui leur convient bien un
enfant en situation d'handicap non donc
là en fait de travail à mi-temps ça me
permet l'après-midi de pouvoir gérer les
rendez-vous quand il y en a et de
pouvoir gérer tout ce qui est taxi et
tout ça de l'embauche sont à prévoir car
en septembre la légumerie a vendu 10
tonnes de produit 15 tonnes en octobre
elle doit se développer il faut qu'on se
touche finance un minimum et pour ça il
faut qu'on monte le volume de production
donc il faut d'une part diversifier je
pensais secteur pour l'instant on
alimente les écoles
scolaires et c'est très important que
les enfants mangent et bien on peut
diversifier augmenter notamment tourne
en tout ce qui secteur sanitaire et
social en verre en direction des EHPAD
des hôpitaux et cliniques et cetera la
pagaie est soutenu par l'Etat la région
le département est la Communauté de
Communes 3cbo elle a investi 100000 €
pour lancer cette figurine insertion